[Music]  do you know why the Phoenix sits on the  right hand at the Opera  she is his guardian his protector that  she's both beautiful and strong your job  is to bring honor to the family do you  think you can do that  citizens we are under attack from  northern invaders their leader calls  himself Oricon fights alongside of which  no survivors  by eating of his Imperial Majesty every  family must contribute one to fight a  few no son I am blessed with two  daughters I will fight  we must be strong  this time you will not return loyal  brave and true it is my duty to protect  my family  [Music]  ancestors please protect her  what is your name soldier partying  commander son of haja we're gonna make  men out of every single one of you  lose again  the spirits is evident as something  holds you back  [Music]  when they find out who you are they will  show you no mercy  [Music]  I'm Hamelin I will bring honor to us all  you  you